we got our first good look at tom
holland as nathan drake
dmc 5 is gonna have a bunch of next-gen
performance modes
and kojima productions is working on its
next game i'm persia and this is your
save state for thursday
october 22nd let's hop into the news
[Music]
tom holland is playing nathan drake in
the upcoming uncharted movie and we just
got our first good look at him as the
iconic character
in fact it was such a good look even
naughty dog game director kurt marginal
complimented it but let's get the
obvious out of the way there's no french
tuck
what's up with that regardless tom
holland's nathan drake
is pretty much spot on in terms of
costuming nathan drake voice actor nolan
north also paid a visit to the set at
one point and said
he was proud to have tom holland
continuing the drake legacy and of
course that tom is absolutely smashing
it
filming just started this past july but
surprisingly it's already almost
complete
the film is expected to hit theaters on
july 16th 2021
double may cry 5 special edition is
coming to next gen
and it offers some special new
performance modes to make the most out
of the next-gen consoles there are four
different performance modes to choose
from the modes have various combinations
that change between 4k
and 1080p retracing on or off or
adjusting your frame rate it all depends
on your preference
however it's also worth noting that ray
tracing isn't coming to the series x
version of the game on day one but it
will be patched in at a later date
dmc 5 special edition comes to the xbox
series xns on november 10th
and to the ps5 on november 12th and if
you want more next-gen coverage like
this then check out gamespot's weekly
show
generation next a little less than a
year from the launch of death stranding
kojima productions has started its next
game predictably there aren't any
details on the new game or if it ties
into death stranding in any way and
it'll probably be
a while before we do hear anything
because if you remember
death training was announced more than
three years before its release
however we do know that the studio is
now hiring for multiple roles like game
programming and design
sound design art writing production
management
and localization also fluency in
japanese is required for
all of the roles although we don't know
too much yet you already know to stay
tuned to gamespot for
any future announcements from kojima
thanks so much for reaching
your save state today and don't forget
to check out our other daily content on
our channel
and at gamespot.com we'll see you guys
later
[Music]